dans le désert de tout mama à une heure
de route de ryad il a toujours soufflé
un certain vent de liberté et famille
saoudienne viennent s'y reposer les
vendredis échapper un peu pour ben eager
comprennent y en des codes de conduite
en société
c'est ici que beaucoup de femmes ont
appris à conduire malgré l'interdiction
pour les saoudiennes de prendre le
volant
certaines se contente de louer un vtt
pour quelques heures d'autres empruntent
la voiture d'un père ou d'un frère
toutes les femmes aiment conduire au
lieu de se fier sur un chauffeur ça
permet d'aller et venir comme on veut
j'ai mes filles ici avec moi elles
apprennent à conduire une voiture
les fils apprenne à leurs femmes à
conduire en syrie et dans tous les pays
arabes
les femmes conduisent rien ne les
empêche et dès juin prochain elle pourra
enfin circuler sur la voie publique
comme les syriennes et les femmes de
partout ailleurs sur la planète
je suis très heureuse et sous le choc
parce que beaucoup de choses sont
arrivées en même temps on a retiré son
pouvoir à la police religieuse
c'était le jour de la fête nationale et
les gens s'amuser il y avait un
sentiment dans le pays de renouveau et
de joie je ne me suis jamais senti comme
ça ça relève le pays
je le vois sur les visages ravis de tout
le monde celui des jeunes en particulier
madiha al ajroush a consacré sa vie
adulte à la lutte pour le droit des
femmes en arabie saoudite
dès 1990 avec près de 50 de ses
concitoyennes et l'april volant des
mains de son chauffeur pour circuler
dans les rues de la capitale
un geste de protestation qui a valu à la
pionnière d'être arrêté et humilié
[Musique]
deux jours après l'événement les
autorités religieuses se sont mises à
dire des choses ignobles à notre sujet
ça ne s'était jamais vu au nom de la
religion ils nous traitaient le
prostitué
c'était horrible pour nous de voir leurs
réactions
nous avons compris qu'on voulait nous
discréditer nous retirer tout le mérite
de nos actions et faire taire nos voix
et ils ont réussi en quelque sorte
à l'époque j'étais assise à la maison
sans savoir ce qui allait se passer
j'ai eu très peur que ces photographes à
l'époque et l'a vu quinze ans de sa
carrière s'envoler en fumée quand les
autorités ont saisi et brûlé tous ses
négatifs pour la punir
ce crédit est un nom
aujourd'hui les femmes se retrouvent à
l'avant scène de l'ambitieux projet de
réforme vision 2030
celle à qui on interdisait carrément le
sport sont maintenant encourager à
courir a frappé le sac ou à lancer le
ballon elles peuvent aussi désormais
assister à des événements sportifs
pendant longtemps ne pouvait pas aller
au gym c'est interdit aux femmes pour
faire de l'exercice on ne pouvait que
marcher autour de la maison et fuites
d'eau est nécessaire
la designer confectionne depuis
longtemps détenus modeste mais pratique
pour les femmes qui souhaite bouger sans
être encombré de la traditionnelle abaya
noire où la femme d'affaires croit
qu'elles offrent bien plus aux femmes qu
un simple vêtement la liberté la liberté
de faire ce qu'elles veulent que ce soit
de conduire une voiture roulait à
bicyclette faire de l'exercice à
l'extérieur en public
tout ça en restant modeste oui je leur
donne la liberté lot et garonne
salvateur
[Musique]
dans une économie qui tourne au ralenti
les femmes et leurs nouveaux droits sont
les bienvenus elles doivent encore se
fier sur un chauffeur pour s'y rendre
mais partout au pays les
concessionnaires automobiles se
bousculent dans les salons de l'auto qui
courtise les femmes
[Musique]
et à défaut de pouvoir déjà en repartir
au volant du dernier modèle certaines se
prépare sur des simulateurs de conduite
mise à leur disposition
jusqu'en grande grotte de glace
tout est en train de changer et je suis
très excité face à ce qui nous attend
l'arabie saoudite a récemment annoncé
que les femmes devraient aussi faire
leur entrée dans l'armée au sein des
services de sécurité
un pas de plus vers leur intégration à
la vie active et saoudienne hausse
croire que tout ça n'est que le début
d'une longue suite de changements
positifs
nous ne sommes plus comme un vent des
femmes au foyer qui ne sortent pas de la
maison et s'occupe des enfants
non mais tu es maintenant on travaille
on est instruite
on a des diplômes d'études j'espère
qu'un jour on sera égale à l'homme -
higuain
un bon sens mais il reste une entrave de
taille à cette quête d'égalité la
tutelle légale qui est imposée aux
femmes saoudiennes
impossible pour elle de voyager à
l'étranger d'ouvrir un compte bancaire
d'obtenir des papiers d'identité de
s'inscrire à l'université ou encore
d'accéder à la justice sans l'accord
d'un homme le plus souvent un père un
mari ou un frère
une femme saoudienne reste pour ainsi
dire une enfant avis se prouve qu'une
chose c'est une forme de contrôle
c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui décide tout
pour la femme qu'il soit sain d'esprit
ou pas cap
la société ne peut pas fonctionner ici
même une femme qui représente son
gouvernement à l'étranger et prend des
décisions pour sa société doit avoir la
permission de son gardien pour voyager
c'est inconcevable qu'on ne peut pas
avoir une femme médecin qui sauvent des
vies mais n'a aucun contrôle sur la
sienne ça ne va pas elle croit que la
société saoudienne est prête non
seulement accepté les femmes seul au
volant
mais pour des réformes plus en
profondeur difficile de dire si elle a
raison
certaines femmes même plus jeunes
trouvent que les changements actuels
vont bien assez loin que l'arabie
saoudite le berceau de l'islam ne doit
pas être secoué aux dépens de ses
principes
[Musique]
mohammed bin salman l'architecte des
changements sociopolitiques et
économiques qui déferle rapidement sur
son royaume ultra-conservateur concentre
les pouvoirs ce qui aurait pu s'élever
contre sa vision d'une société d'un
islam qu'il dit moderne ont été écartés
réduit au silence les imams qui n'ont
pas épousé les nouveaux remparts de ce
qui est admissible dans la sphère
publique ont été démis de leurs
fonctions
pour l'instant les regards réprobateurs
reste furtif et les critiques se
chuchote en privé
[Musique]
ceux qui se réjouissent de cette
évolution craignent que ces désaccords
se transforme en contestation ouverte
plus les femmes sortiront de l'ombre et
viennent menacer ce nouvel horizon qui
n'a jamais été aussi étincelant pour
elle
[Musique]